Jenny is with us in Nashville hi Jenny
how are you great thank you for taking
my call how are you better than I
deserve what's up well I just recently
remarried at work within our soil
I'm just turned 40 and we're starting
over the thing is is we make only about
50,000 a year because I work part-time
and go to school and we pay out just he
pays out an alimony and child support 20
to 5 and then when you add health
insurance and you add mortgage and all
of those things we have very little left
over at the end of the month
we're warning where we actually for
Christmas our Christmas gift to each
other is done starting in getting where
we're going through a financial piece 9
weeks things and our plan is you know we
want to be debt-free and honestly I
don't have a lot of debt I've worked
hard to make sure I don't I don't do
credit cards that I'm doing you that
stuff I just owe on my house and I
hardly and we are going to sell the
Harley ok but I guess my question is
with having so little left you know we
like to give as well how do we what do
you suggest we do as far as getting to
the point where we can pay more or save
more or you know well I mean basically
what you're telling me is is you're
trying to live on about $25,000 a year
Wow
and and how can I give more and pay more
on $25,000 a year and the answer is not
easy it's not you know you've got an
income problem now the alimony is it
fixed is it locked in well we're working
in futuro it's how it was listed but
I've done a lot of research
it should not be that way because she is
not what they said was that she was
unmarketable but she does have an
education degree she is now working as a
substitute teacher but not reporting
that she's working so if she has an
education degree and she's working as a
substitute teacher then that meant she
had a market all I would think so we're
going to fight that that maybe we can
get that how long has he been divorced
he's been divorced two years okay and
how old other children his child that
he's paying child support on his 14 well
we know when that ends and four more
years right right so that's a set
situation so we know that part of the
equation goes away is the alimony have
any set like on if she remarries or
anything like that it does if she
remarries
and and that's all this time we marry
her dance of course careful I know I'm
not working that I'm not I'm kidding
so yeah I guess you you look and see if
there's a legal challenge on her
marketability and if the thing was done
wrong if he rolled over and played dead
in other words in the middle of the
negotiations on the divorce on the
alimony portion the child support you
knew that was there and certainly you
know we're not gonna you're not
suggesting didn't take care of his child
and no one no one with a good conscience
would but 20 to 5 is pretty heavy out of
50 grand 1 so most of that must be a
alimony yes yes it's a almost $1000 I'm
not 5th alimony and then another 866 for
child complaint 66 sounds right yeah
and you know so you just got check and
see you know if there's anything you can
do there and if the is the end the
alimony is locked down based on going
forward meaning if your husband and you
went out and doubled your household
income it doesn't doesn't change the
equation right so you know you know in
other words all the money comes to you
guys and that's what you're facing so
that that's the kind of thing you got to
think about it and you just the reason
your strained is you're trying to live
on $25,000 a year and it can be done but
it's it's very very hard
and so if Financial Peace University is
going to help you but more than anything
you've already identified your challenge
and your challenge is you got 50 coming
in in 2025 going back out and that's
that's just a challenge mathematically
there's no no other way to say it and I
don't hear any weird bitterness or
craziness getting your voice or anything
like that
so I think you guys can probably do some
things to get your income up and I would
go look at the the alimony situation I'd
continue to look at that see if it is
can be challenged I don't know I don't
know anything about that stuff are very
little about it and so you have to see a
good attorney and decide if it's worth
fighting and so on and just work your
way through on those decisions so hey
thanks for the call you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others
Oh